The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GIORGIO METTA: So
I'll be talking
about my work for
the past 11 years.
So this has been,
certainly, exciting,
but also was long in
duration, so we had
to sort of stick to the goal.
And I'll show you also
a couple of things--
I mean, most of this
work has been possible
because we have a team of
people that contributed
to both the design of the
robot and the research
we're doing on
the robot, so I'll
be freely drawing from the
work of these other people.
I just cited them
as the iCub team,
because I couldn't
list everybody there,
but you'll see a
picture later that
shows how many people
were actually involved
in developing this robot.
So our, let's say, goal,
although we didn't start it
like this, is to build robots
that can interact with people,
and maybe one day be
commercially-available to be
deployed in the household.
Everything we've done is--
on the design of
the robot has to do
with a platform
capable of interacting
with people in a natural way.
And this is reflected in
the shape of the robot,
that it's humanoid.
It's reflected in
the type of skills
we tried to implement
in the robot.
And overall on the
design, the platform
excels in terms of strength, in
terms of sensors, and so forth.
There was an, let's
say, hidden reason.
We wanted to design a
platform for research, also,
so when we started,
we didn't think
of a specific application.
Our idea was to have a robot
as complicated as possible
to give researchers the
possibilities of doing whatever
they liked.
So the robot can walk, has
cameras, tactile sensors.
It can manipulate objects.
We put a lot of effort into
the design of the hands.
And it's complicated.
And it breaks often, so it's not
necessarily the best platform,
but it's the--
I believe, the
only platform that
can provide you with
mobile manipulation,
and at the same time with
a sophisticated oculo motor
system in the eyes and cameras.
And maybe it doesn't
give you lasers,
so you have to do
with their vision.
The result is this
platform that's shown here.
This started as a
European project,
so there was an
initial funding that
allowed for basically hiring
people to design the mechanics
and electronics of the robot.
And unfortunately, the
robot is not very cheap.
I mean, the overall--
we tried to put the best
components everywhere.
And this is reflected in
the cost, which doesn't help
diffusion, to a certain extent.
In spite of this,
we managed to, let's
say, "sell," between
quotes, because we
don't make any profit out of
it, 30 copies of the robot.
There are still two of them
to be delivered this year,
so there are, at the
moment, 28 around there.
And four of them are in
our lab, and are used daily
by our researchers.
And given the complexity
of the platform,
we managed, at best, to
build four robots per year.
And at best means that we're
always late in constructions.
We're always late in
fixing the robots.
And that's because, I mean, we
have a research lab trying also
to do-- to have this, let's say,
more commercial side or support
side to the community of users,
which, in fact, doesn't work.
I mean, you cannot ask your PhD
students to go and fix a robot
somewhere in the world.
It was striking a bit that
we managed to actually sell
the robot in Japan.
And that's because,
you know, you
see Japan as the place
of humanoid robots.
And having somebody asking
a copy of our robot there
was a bit strange.
But nonetheless, the project
is completely open-source.
If you go to our website, you
can download all the CAD files
for the mechanics, for
the electronics, all
the schematics, and
the entire software,
from the lowest possible
level up to whatever
latest research has been
developed by our students.
Why we think the
robot is special?
As I said, we wanted
to have hands.
And we put considerable effort
into the design of the hands.
There are nine motors
driving each hand.
And-- although, there are
five fingers and 19 joints,
which means some of
the joints are coupled,
so the actual dexterity of the
hand is all to be demonstrated,
but it works to
a certain extent.
There are some sensors.
It's entirely human-like.
We don't have, for
instance, let's say,
we don't have lasers.
We don't have ultrasound
or other fancy sensors
that, from engineering
standpoint,
could also be integrated.
But we decided to
stick to certain subset
of possible sensors.
There's one thing that
I think is quite unique.
We managed along the
way to run a project
to design tactile sensors.
And so I think it's one
of the few robots that
has almost complete body
coverage with tactile sensors.
There are about 4,000 sensing
points in the latest version.
And we hope to be
able to use them.
I mean, you'll
see certain things
that we started developing.
But for instance, we--
there was discussion
about manipulation
and the availability
of tactile sensors.
We just scratched the
surface in that direction.
We haven't been able to
do much more than that.
As I said, we designed,
also, the electronics.
And the reason
for doing this was
that wanted to be
able to program
the very low-level of the
controllers of the robot.
This didn't pay off for many
years, but at a certain point,
we started doing torque control.
And we started hacking also
the low-level controllers
of the brushless motors.
And so it paid off eventually,
because that wouldn't
have been possible
without the ability
to write low-level software.
Not that many
people are modifying
that part of the software.
It's open-source,
also, that part,
but it's very easy to
burn your amplifiers
if you don't do the right
thing at that level.
And the other thing
is that, as I said,
the platform is reproducible.
And at the moment there
is GitHub repository--
well, a number of GitHub
repositories which contain,
whatever, it's some, a few
millions of lines of code,
whatever it means.
It just means probably
that a lot of students
are just committed
to the repositories,
not necessarily that the
software is super high-quality
at this point.
There are a few modules
that are well-maintained.
And that's the
low-level interfaces,
which is something we do.
Everything else can be in
different ranges of readiness
to be used and things.
Well, why humanoids?
There were, at least at the
beginning, scientific reasons.
One, paraphrasing Rod Brook's
paper, Elephant's Don't
Play Chess, the reason of
developing intelligence
in a robot that
has a human shape
may give an intelligence that
is also comparable to humans,
but also provides for natural
human-robot interaction.
The fact the robot can move
the eyes is very important,
for instance, has
a very simple face,
but it's effective in
communicating something
to the people the robot
is interacting with.
And also, building a
humanoid of a small size--
the robot is only a meter tall--
was very challenging from the
mechatronics point of view.
So for us, engineers,
was a lot of fun too--
the initial few years
when we were designing,
every day was very,
very funny, our--
a lot of satisfaction seeing
that the robot was growing
and being built, eventually.
The fact that the platform
is open-source I think
is also important, allows
for repeating experiments
across different-- in
different locations.
So we can develop
a piece of software
and run exactly the same
module somewhere else
across the world.
And this may, again, give
advantages in-- first of all,
debugging was a lot easier, so
many people complaining when we
do--
when we did something wrong,
and allowed for also, let's say,
shared development, so building
partnerships with many people,
mostly across Europe, because
there was funding available,
so for people to work together.
And this may eventually enable
better benchmarking and better
quality of what we do.
As part of the project, we
also develop middleware.
So maybe you may think that
we have been a bit crazy.
We went from the mechanical
design to the research
on the robot, and passing
through the software
development, but
actually, this was
a middleware that was started
before ROS even existed.
And in fact, it was a
piece of my work at MIT
with a couple of the
students there in 2001, 2002.
So the first version
actually ran on COG
and run on QNX, a
real-time operating system.
Later we did a major
porting to Linux,
and Windows, and MacOS, which--
so we never committed
to a single version.
And that because we had
this community of developers
from the very
beginning, and there
was no agreement on what
development tool to use,
and so we say, why don't
we cover almost everything.
And this part of the
software is actually
very solid at the moment.
This has been,
you know, growing,
not in size, but in
quality, in this case,
so the interfaces remain
practically the same.
And I think the low-level byte
coding of the messages passing
across the network didn't
change since the COG time.
Everything else changed.
It is completely new
implementation now.
But it has portability,
so as I say,
this was a sort of requirement
from the researchers
not to commit to anything,
and so we have developers
using Visual Studio on Windows
or maybe using GCC on Windows,
and other developers running
whatever IDE available
on Linux or MacOS.
And this worked pretty well.
And there's also
language portability.
We can link-- so all
this middleware is just
a set of libraries, so
we can link the libraries
against any language.
And so we have bindings for
whatever, Java, Perl, MATLAB,
and a bunch of other languages.
And this helped
researchers also to do
some rapid prototyping maybe
using Python and so forth.
As I said, the project is
open-source, so you will find,
if you go to the website,
there's a manual,
not particularly
well taken care of.
It works.
At least, it works
with our students,
so it should work for everybody.
But it also, the drawings--
so you can go with drawing like
those to mechanical workshop.
And you get the parts in return.
And then from those,
you can also figure out
how to assemble the components.
Although it's not super-easy.
It's not something you do, just
because you have the drawings,
you do in your basement.
I mean, one of the groups
in one of our projects
tried doing that.
And I think they stopped
after building part of a arm
and maybe part of a leg.
I mean, it was very
challenging for them.
And you need a very, let's
say, a proper workshop
for building the components,
so it takes time, anyway.
Continuing on the sensors, I
mentioned that we have skin.
And I'll show you a bit
more about that in a moment.
But we also have
force-torque sensors,
and gyroscopes,
and accelerometers.
So if you take all these pieces
and you put them together,
you can actually sense
interaction forces
with the environment.
And if you can sense
interaction forces,
you can make the
robot compliant.
And this has been an
important development
across the past few years
that allowed the robot
to move from position
control to torque control.
And this has been
needed, again, to go
in the direction of
human-robot interaction.
And so these are standard
force-torque sensors,
although we designed, as usual.
We spent some time and
designed the sensors.
And this was a reason of cost.
The equivalent six-axial
force-torque sensor,
commercially, cost,
I don't know, $5,000.
And we managed to
build it for $1,000.
So it maybe is not
as super rock-solid
as the commercial component,
but it works well.
And about the skin, this
was a sensing modality
that wasn't available.
And again, we managed
to get funding
for actually running a
project for three years
to design the skin
for the robot.
And we thought it was
a trivial problem,
because at the beginning
of the project,
we already had the idea
of using capacity sensing.
And we actually had a prototype.
And we say, oh, it's trivial.
Then we spent three years
to actually engineer
it to make it work
properly on the robot.
So the idea is trivial, so
since capacity sensing is
available for
cellphones, we thought
of moving that into a version
that would work for the robot.
There were two issues.
First of all, the
robot is not flat,
so we can't just stick cell
phones on the robot body
to obtain tactile sensing.
So we had to make
everything flexible
so they can be conformed to
the surface of the robot.
The other thing is that
the cell phones only
sense objects that are
electrically-conductive.
That's because the way
the sensor is designed,
so we had to change that,
because the robot might
be hitting objects
that are not--
that are plastic, for instance.
So what we've done
was to actually build
the capacitors over two layers.
There's an outer layer
and a set of sensors
that are etched on a flexible
PCB that is shown there.
And what the sensor
measures is actually
the deflection of the outer
layer, which is conductive,
towards the sensors.
And in between, we have
another flexible material.
And that's another part of the
reason why it took so long.
We started with materials like
silicone that were very nice,
but unfortunately, they
degrade very quickly,
so we ended up running sensors
for a couple of months.
And then all of sudden they
started failing or changing
their measurement properties.
We didn't know why.
We started investigating
all possible materials
until we found one that
was actually working well.
The other solution we
had to, basically, design
was the shape of
the flexible PCB.
So we had the challenge
of taking 4,000 sensors
and bringing all the signals
somewhere to the main CPU
inside the robot.
And, of course, you cannot
just connect 4,000 wires.
So what we've done on
the back side of the PCB
there's actually a routing
for all the sensors
from one triangle to
the next until you
get to a digitizing unit.
And-- sorry, each triangle
digitize its own signals.
And they travel in digital form
from one triangle to the next
until they reach a
micro-controller that
takes all these numbers and
sends them to the main CPU.
And this saves on
the connection side,
and so it actually
enables the installation
of the skin on the robot.
So this is a, let's say,
industrialized version
of the skin.
And that's the customization
we've done for a variant arm.
And those are parts of
the skin for the iCub.
So the components that we
just screw onto the outer body
and to make the iCub sensitive.
This is another solution,
which is, again,
capacitive for the fingertips,
simply because the triangle was
too big, too large for the
size of the iCub fingertips,
but the principle
is exactly the same.
It was just more
difficult to design
these flexible materials,
because they are just
more complicated to fabricate
on those small sizes.
And the result, when you
combine the force-torque sensors
and the tactile
sensors is something
like this, which is a compliant
controller on the iCub, where
you can just push
the robot around.
This is in
zero-gravity modality.
So you can just push the robot
around and move it freely.
And this has to be compared to
the complete stiffness in case
you do position control.
And another thing that is
enabled by force control
is teaching and demonstration.
This is a trivial experiment.
We just recorded
trajectory and repeated
exactly the same
trajectory, so it's not--
I mean, you can do
learning on top of that,
but we haven't done it.
It's just to show that the
fact that you can control--
the robot in torque
mode enables these type
of tasks, so teaching
a new trajectory that
was never seen by the robot.
There's another less
trivial thing you can do.
Since we can sense
external forces,
you can do something
like this, which
is, we can build
a controller where
you keep the robot compliant.
You impose certain
constraints on the center
of mass and the
angular momentum,
and keep the robot, basically,
stable in that configuration
like this one, in spite
of external forces being,
in this case,
generated by a person.
This is part of a
project that is basically
trying to make the iCub walk,
more or less, efficiently.
And as part of the
project, we actually
also redesigned the ankles of
the robot, because, initially,
we didn't think of
bipedal walking,
and so they weren't
strong enough to support
the weight of the robot.
And this is basically
the same stuff
that was shown on
the previous videos,
just the same
combination of tactile
and force-torque sensing used
to estimate counter forces.
We actually added two
more force-torque sensors
in the ankles, so
we have six overall
here in this version
of the robot.
Now, as part of this,
we also played a bit
with machine learning.
For mapping the tactile
formation and force-torque
sensor information
to the joints,
since they are not localized
on the joints of the robot,
we have--
and also for separating what
we measure with the sensors
from the forces generated
by the movement of the robot
by its internal
dynamics, we have
to have information
about the robot dynamics.
And this is something we can
do, or we can build a model
for using machine learning,
since we have measurements
from the joint position
velocities and accelerations,
and the torques measured from
the force-torque sensors,
we can compute the
robot dynamics.
And this can be done either
using a let's say, computer
model from the CAD,
or from learning
the model via machine learning.
And so we collect the
data set from the iCub.
In this case, it was a
data set for the arm,
for the first four joints.
We didn't do anything
for the rest.
And in this case, we used--
we sort of customized a
specific method, which
has custom processes,
to be incremental,
and also to be
computationally-bounded
in time, so we wanted
to avoid the explosion
of the computational
time due to the increase
in the number of samples.
And this was-- well, it was
basically an interesting piece
of work because everything
we do on the robot,
if it's inserted
in a control loop,
has to have a predictable
computation time,
and possibly limited enough
so that we can run the control
loop at reasonable rates.
And this is some of the results.
And actually, we also compare
with other existing methods.
This is just to show that
the method we developed,
which uses an approximate
kernel, works pretty much
as well as a standard
Gaussian process
regression in this
case, and works
much better than other
methods from the literature.
This was just to
have a rough idea
that this was entirely doable.
Also, by shaping
the kernel, it's
possible to compensate
for temperature drifts.
Unfortunately, the
force-torque sensors
tend to change response
due to temperature,
not that the lab is
changing temperature,
but often, the electronics
itself is heating up
around the robot, so
it's making the sensor
read something
different, and but it's
possible to show that,
again, through learning,
you can build a
compensation also
for the temperature
variations just
by shaping the kernel to include
a term that depends on time.
This is one example
of how we've done
machine learning on the
robot, although the problem is
fairly simple.
A problem that is
more complicated
is learning about objects.
So in this scenario, we--
targeting is shown
here, where we have,
basically, a person that
can speak to the robot,
tell the robot that
it's a new object.
And the robot's
acquiring images.
And we hope to be able to
learn about objects from-- just
from these type of images.
This is maybe the most
difficult situation.
We can also lie
objects on the table
and just tell the robot to
look at a specific object,
and so forth.
Again, the speech
interface is nice,
because you can basically
also attach labels
to the objects that
are what it's seeing.
The methods we tried, in the
recent past, we've done--
we basically applied
sparse coding
and then regularized least
squares for classification.
This was basically how we
started a couple of years ago.
And more recently, we used an
off-the-shelf convolutional
neural network.
And again, the classifiers
are linear classifiers.
And this, I mean, has proved
to work particularly well,
but also, since we aren't
the robot, we can, let's say,
play tricks.
One trick that is easy to
apply, and it's very effective,
is actually, you're
seeing an object,
but you don't have
a single frame.
You can actually take subsequent
frames, because the robot may
be observing the objects for
a few moments, for seconds,
whatever.
And in fact, there's
an improvement
that is shown in this plot
there, the one to the right.
If you increase the
number of seconds
you're allowed to
observe the object,
you improve, also, performance.
And the plot is over
the number of classes,
because we also like to improve
on the number of classes
that a robot can
actually recognize,
and which was limited until,
let's say, a couple of years
ago, but now, with all these
new deep-learning stuff,
it seems to be
improving quite a lot,
and our experiments
in that direction.
There's another thing
that can be done,
which is try to see what
happens if we have--
since we have, again, the
robot interacting with people
for entire days, if we collect
images on different days,
and then we can play
with different conditions
on the testing case.
So for instance, the
different plots here
show what happens if you train
and test on the current day,
so you train cumulatively
on up to four days
and you test on
the last day only.
And you see, of course,
performance improve
as you increase the train set.
Conditions may be slightly
different from one day
to the next.
Light may have changed,
just because it was more
a sunny day or a cloudy day.
And the other conditions are
to test also on past days
or to test on future
days, so where conditions
may have changed a lot.
And in fact, performance
is slightly worse
in that situation.
OK and this is a video that
shows, basically, the robot
training and some of the
experiment on testing
how the robot perceives
a number of objects.
And unfortunately,
there's no speech here,
but this basically a
person talking to the robot
and telling the robot
what is the name
for this specific object, then
putting another object there,
drawing the robot's attention
to the object, and then, again,
telling the name.
This is the Lego.
It becomes faster in a moment.
OK, and then you can continue
training basically like that.
And the video shows
also testing--
was showing a bunch of objects
simultaneously to the robot.
And here, we simply click
on one of the objects
to draw the robot's attention.
And on the plot there,
you see the probability
that a given object is being
recognized as the correct one.
OK, I think I have
to cut this short,
because I'm running out of time.
Another thing I
wanted to show you
is, basically, now we have this
ability to control the robot.
We have the ability
to recognize objects.
We also have the ability
to grasp objects.
And this is something
that uses stereo vision.
And in this case,
what we wanted to do
is to present an object to
the robot, no prior knowledge
about the shape of the object.
We take a snapshot.
We reconstruct a stereo pair.
We have to construct
the object in 3D.
And then we apply optimization,
constrained optimization,
to figure out a
plausible location
for the palm of the hand.
And then that will
maximize the ability
to grasp the object
by closing the finger
around that particular position.
This is our, let's say,
definition of power grasp.
So put the palm of
the hand of the robot
in a region of the object
that has a surface, which
has a similar shape or a
similar size of the palm itself,
and where the
orientation is compatible
with the local orientation
of the surface.
And this works
with mixed results.
So it works with
certain objects.
It doesn't work always.
There are objects that
are intrinsically more
difficult for this
procedure, so some of them
will only be grasped with
65% probability, which
is not super-satisfactory.
If you run long
experiments, you want
to grasp three, four objects,
you start seeing failures.
It becomes boring to
actually do the experiments.
So it works well
for soft objects,
for instance, as expected.
We moved a bit
into the direction
of using the tactile sensors,
and-- but at this point,
we've only been able to try
to characterize forces out
of the force of the
tactile sensor measurement.
So we-- basically, taking a
fingertip, we have 12 sensors,
and we're trying to--
and this is another case where
we apply machine learning
trying to reconstruct
the force direction
and intensity from the
tactile sensor measurements.
And this is basically
the procedure,
is we take the sensor.
We move our six-axial
force-torque sensor.
We take the data.
And we approximate this,
again, with a Gaussian process.
Just one last video, if I can.
OK, so basically, we've put
together all these skills.
We may be able to do something
useful with the robot.
In this case, the video
shows a task where
the robot is cleaning a table.
And it's actually using
the grasp component,
and the ability to move the
object, to see the object,
recognize them, and
grasp them, and put them
at a given location,
which was pre-specified,
in this case, so
it's not recognized
that this a container.
It's just putting things there.
And there's one last skill
that I didn't have time
to talk about, which is
recognizing certain objects as
tools, and one specific
object, like this one.
An object like the
tool here can actually
be used for pulling
another object closer.
And this is, again,
something that
can be done through learning.
So we learn the size of the
sticks or set the sticks,
and we also learn how good
they are for pulling something
closer through experience,
by, basically, trial
and error over many trials.
And the result is
that you can actually
generate a movement that
pulls the object closer
so they can later be grasped.
And that's basically
a couple of ideas
on how to exploit the
object affordances, not
just recognizing
them, but also knowing
that certain objects have
certain extra functions which
may end up being useful.
OK, I just wanted to acknowledge
the people that are actually
working on all this.
I promised that I will do that.
And this is actually a
photo around Genoa showing
the group that has been mainly
working on the iCub project
over--
let's say, this is
the group last year,
so there may be more
people that just left,
or some of them moved to MIT.
OK, thank you.